hey guys something seems to be just
wrong with Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi gabbard's
a congresswoman from Hawaii who is
running for president she's polling
about 0.8 percent right now in an
average of recent polls and she put out
this total grandstanding video about how
she might be boycotting tonight's fourth
Democratic presidential debate a pre
announcement that she may have a further
announcement to make about boycotting
the debate if she decides to I'm not
even gonna play the video itself because
it's such cringe-worthy grandstanding
but you can find the video online but
here's the tweet where she posts the
video saying I am seriously considering
boycotting October 15 debate to bring
attention to DNC corporate media's
effort to rig 2020 primary not against
Bernie this time but against voters in
early states Iowa New Hampshire and
presumably South Carolina
so Tulsi is announcing that she may have
a boycott to announce first she
complained that the standards were
unfair for the third debate which she
didn't make right the standards unfairly
kept her out of the debate in reality
the standards for the third debate were
too low and the third debate ended up
being filled with people that have
absolutely no chance of winning the
nomination now she makes the fourth
debate qualifies for the fourth debate
and she might boycott but instead of
just announcing a boycott she announces
that she's considering a boycott it's
the most boring attention trolling and
grandstanding and it's stunning that her
followers are actually seeing this as
principled and sort of powerful in some
bizarre way I looked around a little bit
at comments about her pre announcement
announcement and the tulsi sycophants
are just titillated by this video and
the threat to boycott the DNC's rules
have nothing to do with her having no
chance at this nomination she never had
a shot she plays coy with Republican
framing of the issues she plays this
enlightened centrist role it's also
boring and this is such a
sprit attention-seeking move no one
other than her sycophants is even paying
attention to her campaign and reducing
the number of people on the stage
tonight would be a good thing I hope she
boycotts the debate I don't think she
will but it would make the debate more
watchable and maybe we would allow us to
learn a little more about the positions
of the candidates that actually have a
shot and here she is sort of threatening
to boycott but not just saying I'll
boycott it never mind that it would be
much more useful I mean listen if I were
her and I had this position about how
it's all rigged again and I'll address
that in a second I think the best thing
to do would be show up at the debate and
talk during the debate about how you
believe it to be rigged right rather
than a twitter video where you talk
about you might subsequently announce
that you are boycotting it because as
you see it is rigged I hope she does
boycott just to get her off the stage
but I don't think that she's going to
now as far as the DNC is a bad actor of
course of course the DNC is a bad actor
they were a bad actor in 2016 this year
they're allowing networks to run these
debates in this horrible for-profit
pandering game show like away I can't
stand where the first question often
doesn't even get asked until like twenty
five minutes into the debate but the
requirements aren't strict enough
stricter requirements would reduce the
number of people on stage they would get
us more speaking time for the people
that actually have a shot we're just a
few months from the first votes being
cast and it would be great to actually
clear the stage a little bit but there
are you know there are plenty of
criticisms that you can make of the DNC
but Tull sees polling at 0.8 percent no
one cares if she boycotts and quite
frankly I hope that she does in order to
give the people who have a shot more
speaking time because I want to hear
from them in depth their understanding
of and ideas about how to solve the
pressing issues of our day if you really
want to criticize the DNC go to the
debate criticize it during the debate
instead of this pre boycott announcement
that you may be boycotting at some point
in the future I know people are going to
some people are gonna be upset with me
about this I know that the tulsi
sycophants are disproportionately loud
and they'll come and they'll dislike my
YouTube video and they'll leave comments
about you know I'm a DNC shill or this
or that or the other thing I don't care
this is the most boring form of
political grandstanding
and it is stunning truly stunning that
there are people who are seeing this as
some kind of really big important and
principled move from the powerful Tulsi
Gabbard give me a break your polling
0.8%
do whatever you want I hope you boycott
but I assume that you'll be there